je vous emmène aujourd'hui au Mondial de
l'automobile pour vous présenter une
marque une marque vietnamienne qui
s'appelle vinfast vous avez à la fois un
design italien des technologies
allemandes et un accueil vietnamien
modèle 100% électrique vous êtes prêts
allez c'est parti je vous montre la VF 8
on a design qui est fait par Pininfarina
et surtout ce qui est intéressant ici
c'est que vous avez vraiment une
signature au niveau des lumières
signature en forme de V on a bien
évidemment à l'avant mais également à
l'arrière et si vous avez un V sur le
côté un V qui part comme ça et qui
redescend par là et là il y a un truc
qui est aussi très atypique et qui est
vachement sympa c'est une cassure au
niveau de la cour regardez vous avez
votre courbe qui va là qui va là et là
elle se comble légèrement sur le bas ça
permet d'avoir l'arrière du véhicule un
peu plus marqué dans la vf9 vous avez un
très grand écran central vous avez même
un petit écran à l'arrière vous avez
plein de connectique à l'arrière ici de
l'usba 2 USBA et usb-c et même encore
ici un autre USB vous avez énormément de
place dans cette vf9 2 à l'avant trois
au centre et de l'arrière autant dire
que si vous voulez partir en famille ou
avec beaucoup de potes là vous avez
vraiment de quoi faire voilà pour cette
découverte de vinfas on traverse ces
deux modèles la vf8 la vf9 et foncez
découvrir vin face sur leur site web
vous allez voir c'est